[Music]
my ride back from work on June 3rd 2017
was not your typical commute I was in
the backseat of a white pickup truck
with temperatures outside edging up to
115 degrees the roof of our car was
painted with a humanitarian symbol so
that we wouldn't be hit by an air strike
that summer I was an aid worker in
northern Iraq during the final stages of
the operation against Isis in Mosul
after a 10-hour day in the fields
covered in dust all I wanted was to get
home and take a cold shower
but the day wasn't over yet as my
colleagues and I made her way home we
started hearing reports that
neighborhoods in Mosul were filling with
poisonous gas Twitter was lighting up
with these cell phone images showing
aircraft firing white sprays of smoke
into the city it was quickly identified
as white phosphorus used by the us-led
coalition and the Iraqi army white
phosphorus can be used legitimately and
more as a smokescreen to obscure
military movements but when humans come
into contact with it it can also burn
flesh off of the bone so depending on
how it's used it can either be a totally
legitimate tactic of war or war crime
and sometimes it's nearly impossible to
tell the difference my colleagues began
to argue should we demand an
international outcry for the for the
coalition's use of chemicals in a
densely populated city or given that
it's a gray area should we focus energy
on other problems it was a judgment call
a decision made by a handful of
well-meaning humanitarians we decided
not to push it
I was left confused by the whole
incident how could something as weighty
as a war crime be so slippery so hard to
pin down back in the States
I began studying war crimes and I
quickly learned that there's no clear
answer and the technology of war is
evolving so quickly the question is only
becoming more urgent the concept of war
crimes originates in the earliest eras
of human history ancient codes of war
from China India and Greece regulated
troops conduct today the laws of war
provide guidance on who qualifies as
combatants the limits of the
battlefields and what sorts of acts are
permissible troops must wear uniforms
they should avoid civilians they can't
torture prisoners things like that when
you think about it it's actually kind of
bizarre acts that would ordinarily land
you in jail like taking someone's life
or destroying a building are totally
legal if you're at war but even in war
there's a category of actions that
humanity has decided is beyond the pale
and those we call war crimes
we even have tribunals that attempt to
bring perpetrators to justice like
following the Rwandan genocide or ethnic
cleansing in the Balkans to me there's
something profound about humans
attempting to bring integrity and ethics
into battle but in practice it's not so
easy to draw the line partially because
war is really messy and chaotic but also
because it turns out there is no clear
universal definition of a war crime ask
any international lawyer and you'll get
this circular answer a war crime is a
serious violation of the laws of war
what's a serious violation of the laws
of war a war crime
as a result historically courts have
sometimes struggled to decide is
terrorism a war crime is rape is
recruiting child soldiers if it seems
confusing now it's about to get a whole
lot worse technology being developed
right here in Silicon Valley
artificial intelligence autonomous
vehicles drones is the same technology
that will dictate the future of war and
it's evolving so rapidly it's already
outpaced the law we're headed for a
legal black hole where anything goes
in particular technology is complicating
the three areas where law used to
provide clarity who is like who are the
combatants where is the battlefield and
what are the harms first who are the
combatants picture a fully autonomous AI
powered weapon system to be clear this
doesn't exist yet but it's not
inconceivable it's been pre-programmed
to strike enemy targets without human
intervention it may actually be more
precise and accurate less less prone to
error but it's imperfect and let's say
it's somehow commits a horrendous act
like targeting a hospital instead of a
military base
what can we hold responsible technology
creates a massive accountability gap war
crimes are committed by combatants but
our computer programmers and
manufacturers combatant unless it could
be proven that they were somehow aware
of a defect they're simply too far
removed from the crime and would it even
be fair to charge an engineer in Palo
Alto with war crimes committed halfway
around the globe second where is the
battlefield imagine a nuclear explosion
in space creates an electromagnetic
pulse that reaches Earth's atmosphere
causing aircraft to fall from the sky or
imagine a cyber attack launched from a
suburban living room
that wipes out a power grid in another
country the law of work tries to keep
destruction on the battlefields but
there's no standalone regulation of
warfare in space and there's no
consensus on the limits of cyber war
words of the future will rarely look
like two armies meeting on the
battlefields war will be fought from
remote locations and it will be carried
out in outer space
and in digital space and third what are
the harms the law of war usually
conceives of harm in terms of physical
damage violence bloodshed destruction
but new weapons will cause different
harms like environmental damage
imagine a weapon leaves behind toxic
remnants that slowly destroys farmland
leaving it inhospitable or imagine a
cyberattack that destroys information
medical records financial data we
haven't yet decided if those sorts of
harms should be off limit and war does a
war crime require physical pain physical
destruction these questions are not
easily answered the law of war was
created before artificial intelligence
even before the Internet
we're retrofitting rules from the 19th
and 20th century to a new world
and frankly these are questions that no
one wants to think about the latest
version of the United States official
guidelines on autonomous weapons is no
more than a couple page PDF document
with track changes left on that's
terrifying some say it's not worth
establishing legal guidelines if you're
not sure that we can hold people
accountable anyway
some say that regulation will stifle
innovation I say it's a cop-out I don't
have all the answers but my instinct is
that war is and should remain a uniquely
human endeavor there should be
meaningful human control over life and
death decisions for sure technology can
do a lot to improve defense
and reduce risk for servicemembers and
civilians we can never fully delegate
moral agency to a machine and we should
resist the temptation to try at Stanford
were tasked with thinking up the
unimaginable the new business idea the
moonshot invention the sobering side of
that mandate is the duty to also
consider the harms what the adverse
actor might do if given a chance or the
well-meaning actor who simply has no
legal guidance this isn't limited to
warfare ethics should be a central
component of all technology design not
an afterthought the mere act of writing
down standards helps to build a
consensus on what's acceptable and what
isn't we can't trust that existing law
has all of the answers as is clear with
war crimes it may have very few war is a
tragic reality but the decisions we make
today can ensure that it is constrained
to the battlefields and the soldiers who
fight on it thank you
[Applause]
[Music]